well I thought I was going to giving a
blackboard talk but I thought this might
be more effective to deliver ideas there
are a lot of figures to draw so this is
about this is talking about an
observation of a some ground state wave
function that arrives from consideration
from a particular quantum erikak writing
code but I'm not not gonna talk about
quantum error correction at all and this
exemplifies a state where previous
concept of RG and Mira really does not
apply so here is a concrete example that
you might want to consider further so
let me just explain what the model is
and later on I will give the what the RG
calculation was this is a spin model
defined on the three-dimensional lattice
and there there I put two qubits purse
each site the interaction term is crazy
it is products of eight Pauli matrices
one of Sigma X type and the other of
Sigma Z type and each of the term is
product of operators arranging this form
this model is exactly solvable in the
sense that each term commutes with with
with one another because for instance if
this interaction term were placed at
here then this bird s will meet but
there hit the overlap and if the
interaction term is placed along this
edge then there is an anti commiting
pair but they appear in the even number
as always the case he can be meet in a
at a face but then you will have again
even number of anti committing pairs and
this model has a property bad shape that
is shared with the many topological
order systems in the sense that it has a
locally indistinguishable ground state
more precisely it means that if you have
some arbitrary local operator
and if you know that that operator
commutes with Hamiltonian so that it
acts on the ground space then he must be
a product of terms in the Hamiltonian
whose eigenvalues are already known to
be plus one so it should act as a just
scalar multiplication which is trivial
and one very peculiar property of this
model is that you can separate what it
is all about the isolating ex-patients
on the left hand side so there is
another local operation we can do this
that is a we can imagine we can insert a
layer of products days later of products
data so you have 3d cube model you can
just become an you can add oh just one
layer two layer okay now these Cooley
there you just put a plastic okay then
there is the issue we that's kind of
local operation RKO of solve such a
layer into into this cubic hope so what
I can say that like these things could
be a distinction between the cubic and
the fantastic seems you can insert of a
line of products tape and somehow
scramble thing gonna come out that comes
solve this line into it absorbs of
neither satisfied by things from a local
unitary transformation but I wonder
whether if you do this kind of a design
productive real freedom
mm-hm what that is so basically what I'm
approaching Tony Matassa well the lower
unit rate is the only local operation
are one can generate having to buy that
they added these products things also
it's kind of generalize local
oh I say so sir your question is I in
the previous slide I only consider the
local operator to commit you to X on the
given lattice whereas if you if I
introduced ancillary degrees of freedom
and adds on that what would happen as
one of these it doesn't look very like a
common socrata sings they are locally
single so adding an ancillary system
amounts to having a non unitary operator
but also some arbitrary operator on on
the system but this calculation doesn't
depend on that so well given any any
linear operator it doesn't have to be
the unitary but you can compose it in
terms of linear current server sorry
linear combination of unitary operators
and for each of them this holds so let
me cut okay come back coming back to
talk let me contrast the phenomenology
of this model with the conventional
things and the convention of theme
I chose of the conventional to historic
code here you had the similar
interaction terms is that one segment is
there time in Sigma X type speaking on a
square lattice of two dimensions you
have a point like excitation and if you
apply a certain local operation that
forms a string then you can arbitrarily
isolate your point like excitation
however in the cubicle case there exists
a point like excitation and the
separation is possible but the process
different process must be taken in this
very complicated fashion
you have to do some self-similar
operator itself similar operation such
that in order to separate these red dots
for arbitrary bar only Lucy blue bits
are the points where operator you have
act and the red dots are the file a of
terms in your Hamiltonian that's just an
observable changes right this is Elias
these all absorb what this observer is
the red dots however in order to obtain
such an isolated isolated configuration
of excitation you have to go through
some complicated process help create the
stream ectasia using kind of like a
Montreal breaker yes you can but that's
a Franco oh it's not no well why is a
stream coming crazy without right yeah
right that's better
and because of that reason as an
application to the quantum memory then
it has a very pretty long memory time
although it does not diverge with the
system size and you can interpret that
answer a slow dynamics from the ground
state to some thermal state good Mesa
you is a relaxation time that depends
somehow on the system size although it
has a massive value that is independent
of system size then it's qualitatively
different behavior from the previous
models so compared to a 3d for wholly
that's a maximal value being equal
debating around a bigger square
brightness that was a brief overview of
the kibbeh code and one another strange
thing under the periodic boundary
conditions or L by L by L and the
degeneracy is always a power of two with
some integer exponent but the exponent
as a function of system size is a crazy
function it's not a smooth function at
all and the formula I can give you is
this the exponent K is given by degree
of greatest common divisor of these
sorry Omega is third root of unity over
a binary field so it's not an
explanation of 2 PI over 3
it's it has nothing to do with that it's
just that some algebraic number can find
over NT T is just a formal variable just
to account a degree it has no physical
meaning
at least you can rid of with this
calculation quite easily because if the
system size is a power of two maybe it's
a fun calculation over binary field this
seemingly false formula is true because
all the intermediate term will have a
some point patient that is a multiple of
two which is zero so in here eight could
be one or mega or Omega square if I
raise it to some power of two then this
whole but one plus one is zero so you
have some constant times T to the power
2 to the power T so every factor will
have a TTL better therefore the degree
of will be Dell
you don't have six imprecise gross you
never you know this envelope which kind
of trace on a maximum be generally what
is the envelope this is port for L so
it's on Tobruk not exponential
no well it's it's the K is algebraic but
the total degeneracy is exponential of
that so totally members of the system in
SI system be that exponential
exponential of diameter over the year
right all right so the entropy the
entropy per volume vanishes but what is
the DISA what is this a form after you
had an SL pestle as a year as a linear
expression so what is a you know there's
some number there if you know the more
precise form oh well all waiting for
this family of system sizes you have a
expression so the degeneracy in the in
the maximum size hippo pink which you to
be four and roughly
or
so let's look at that wave function the
original goal of this whole analysis and
we generally look at the entanglement
however speaking of entanglement is
fight and beat use terminology is we can
define an entangled entropy for
arbitrary part partition but there are
exponentially many if I plot such a
possible fight partition and we don't
want to work with that huge set of
numbers so we need some more refined or
more coarse set of numbers or objects
that we can develop our understanding
right and I insist that those
entanglement of the grounds grants
things from stateless vendors to in
terms of some renormalization group for
it just to remind you what the RG is
it's just the process where first you
group a set of nearby pivots and choose
a right right correct representative
cubed for each block and you compute the
effective interaction or effective
contentment
among those representatives and so the
question of the kept analysis of RG
relies on how you how you how would you
choose the representative for each one
and for this analysis I demand the
representative to be the unitarily
related to the corresponding block so
I'm a hollow myself to apply arbitrary
unitary to that particular block and I
will pick out one particular
so just so just to repeat local
entanglement
I don't want to focus on that which
which I managed to say that I can apply
arbitrary local research transformation
so if this defines with equivalence
relation among states that you want to
understand if they are released by local
unitary then we demand that what we
assert them there are equal in in order
to choose a right represented to the
guiding principle is that we want to
disentangle as much as possible so if
you apply some unitary and discover that
for your choice of unitary
transformation 80 some percent among
four say to keep its artistic tangle
from be at rest and I can safely throw
this away because this definite cubism
will be anyway does not affect the
long-range intended pattern however it
is not guaranteed that you will be able
to pick just single representative you
will be have you'll be have to you might
be have to want tour more cookies to
representing containment with other
floss properly and then after choosing
the right represented representative I
will risk kill the system to recover at
the event scale
so let's do it for the familiar mistake
its Porto Rico if I work in a cinema if
I work in the basis where Sigma X is in
the diagonal then the ground state
consists of loops and the way to
understand that is if we start with uh
some some product state and then applies
one particular plot head term that will
introduce some loop in the ground state
and since my Hamiltonian has demands
that croustade to be plus one eigen
value of this operator for all of them I
should superpose them all to have the
plus one eigen value so my ground state
will be the soup of such news the loop
as long as is close loop there's no
length scale other than the short
distance cutoff given by the lattice
constant
so if I found if I find some unitary
such that I make the loop into a point
and I can forget about that point
can be if you can do and you can do this
calculation precisely and discover that
to the authority of his on his will is
internationally invariant after
discarding such a decent angle and the
same is true for Letterman model and the
quantum total model
so although examples of topological
order system with in two dimensions are
entanglement with minimization fixed
points in this case rise to the so
called mirror description where you
start with the single qubit and then you
apply certain products of local you in
charge transformation in the quantum
information language is just a quantum
circuit of bounded range and then you
expand your letters and then you insert
some ancillary qubits into the lattice
and you apply another layer of toilet
circuit to this to the new system and
you extend lattice and you keep doing it
I mean it can decay in the end of this
process you will get your desired estate
i I've read the description of Mara in a
reverse order
usually we will learn the route mirror
starting from the actual state and apply
to you Terry and throw something away
but I can't people II understand it in
the reverse order now let's get back to
the original problem of truly code state
and just as the Toriko state was a soup
of loose the ground state of cubic code
is also a soup of something however I
cannot give any
geometrical interpretation for them for
that object it has a some some sphere
loop is purely like thing but it has
some crazy
freckle like thing I don't know how to
mean I just called it something
so here's a result the result is very
simple to state
I found a quantum circuit of constant
death although that is quite large is 32
you have a 32 layers of control lots and
discover that after application of this
this becomes a penser product of two pro
two states one of which is exactly the
same as before we find on the course
that it's with the lattice constant to a
ship the a was the lattice constant of
the original list and something else
that is not equal to the original but
this one can be ended it turns out to be
a ground state of another Hamiltonian
and the Hamiltonian I'm sorry before
describing that I can to the same
analysis for this extra piece that is
newly discovered then I find another
quantum circuit of depth about hundred
that these entangles is new ground state
into two copies of itself remarkably the
two copies are the same as before except
for the length scale and the new state
the promised new state is first is a
ground state of this Hamiltonian the
Hamiltonian leaves on the cubic lattice
fourth with the four cubits per site and
the interaction terms are there are four
types a two with Sigma X product of C
maps and two with product of Sigma C
again they are all commuting exactly
solvable and the ground state is
precisely this
in the phenomenology at the very crude
level is identical to the original cubic
term it has very funny degeneracy
formula it has point like stations
although isolating them would require
very complicated operation and it has
the generate ground state on which there
is no local observable this bifurcating
renormalization group flow directly
leads you to the tensor Network
description which is called branching
mirror where normally you would have a
you would have this dis branch now you
have a multi-player branches at every
level well the construction of
understanding the branching memory is
the same is before you start with the
sub qubits but not now the single qubits
for several all of them you apply some
quantum circuit on each copy
independently and you expand the lettuce
and you merge them you apply another
layer of a quantum circuit and you
expand on that is and you keep doing it
and in the enterprise in the limit of
this process you will get the desired
State
to make sure you never get a little
comfortable it's all this original model
well yes Orson on what model will will
will be in one branch if you all the
other will be the new you know favor
you mean already know Cuba code to be
run by Mira was only one one no original
típico state leaves on the very very
bottom yeah but if you apply the
disentangle and transformation that you
have to describe it as a tensor product
of true one of which is the same as
before but the other is not so so on a
top level you'll say which one is the
original one maybe the other feel is the
new one you have that picture
well the ground space is isomorphic to
that has a product of the whole thing
because I am okay I only apply unitary
however the description of each branch
the original one is continuing than the
single agreements and the all the rest
is two newly-discovered
a new model with the more complicated
interactions you might wonder about the
integrant entropy about this French
mirror so let me derive the
entanglements upper bound an
entanglement repeat by understanding the
mirror first well you started with a
single qubit and you have a glide
quantum circuit that is of constant
death death will increase your intended
entropy for a given block along the
boundary so if you will add at most this
much later you're expanding ìletís your
so your effective linear dimension of
your of your region has increased so if
you apply another layer of quantum
circuit and the additional contribution
will be of this form where the linear
size is doubled again along the
boundaries you keep doing it so in the
end you will reach a region whose leader
system size is some parallel to where
the exponent is the number of layers you
have applied the quantum circuit and
that original and scale that you started
with
so well contain the entropy for a box is
upper bounded by contributions from all
of those it's just a simple sound and it
turns out that this formula so if
capital D is 1 which means we are
working online and this sum is lower
with me well this factor is just
constant and you have logarithm in many
journals however if you go to higher
dimensions where these greater than 1
then exponential factor easily this is
geometry to some so is bounded by area
and the same thing well sorry so what if
you had a multiple branch then you will
have a this contribution for each branch
so you just multiply the number of
branch at that level and use just
something over so in the cubic hub case
where the branching occurs the number of
French is two to the T or T is the level
of your our team and the dimension is
three so if you plug in here then the
number of branches nut is not too fast
to kill your area long so although you
have branching the number since the
branch number of branches sufficiently
small you're okay you're you're still in
that area logging
surprisingly if the dimension is 2 then
you are not allowed to have more than
more than one branch at each level as
long as your state of base your base the
area law
so the branching the gapped and all
these things becomes consistent when you
go to 3 or higher dimensions so how did
I calculate those like a hundred then I
have that hundreds concert how did I
obtain them it will be brief
however more I can deliver a bit of the
main idea so the Hamiltonian is
frustration-free in the ground state is
defined by this stabilizing equation
where s is one of what any of those
terms of Amazonia so if I apply certain
unitary operator on the ground state
then I can't find analogous stabilizer
operator obviously by this trivial
equation my conjugation and if I find
found found that this conjugated
operator turns out to be a poly operator
acting on a single qubit then because of
this frustration-free condition I can
immediately tell that that particular
qubit must be TC entangled from the rest
otherwise I would break the
frustration-free information so I will
find try to find some unitary such that
my stabilizer will be mapped to a single
qubit operator and there's another fact
that is special to this Hamiltonian that
it is the sole information that we have
to care about blinding the information
about the position of Sigma s s Sigma s
and operator and since the Hamiltonian
is translational invariance I don't have
to address a whole lattice I can just
focus on the local terms
well another brief detour tourists our
explanation method that if you have a
bunch of once that is related by
translation by one unit say in this case
to the left one one one is left
translated to the left how would I
describe this matrix all I have to carry
is the arrangement of ones here so I
introduce an auxiliary perhaps
meaningless or physically X represents
its translation to the left but anyway I
write them of some power of s whenever
there is one and the position of that
one is encoded in the exponent and I
place on place a holder which is happen
to be a plus sign and I write down the
matrix in this form well because I I
started with the translation invariant
matrix the resulting polynomial the next
one is obtained by multiplying X to the
earth the previous one because that will
raise the your exponent language so all
I have to remember is this one for that
translation invariant matrix
the same thing happened same thing can
be applied for lettuce hamiltonians by
this correspondence previously we had a
one direction of translation say to the
left but in the lattice we will have a
multiple directions to the X to the Y
and to the N to the Z in the three
dimensions so I associate a coordinate
with the monomial whose exponents are
encoding the given coordinates so
suppose I I am required to describe this
how the operator Sigma X ad came on this
point and Sigma Z acting on that point
and Sigma Y and at that point then I can
just write down the polynomial whose all
per row describes the Sigma X part so
Sigma X part appears at 0 comma 1 comma
0 which is included here X to the 0 Y to
the 1 seem to be 0 and Sigma Y up to
face factor is a multi is a sigma x
times Sigma Z so I can interpret it as
as having a Sigma X component and this
point at this point is according to this
this description is just C + + is just a
placeholder or implicitly meaning that
there are x and we're at a sequin z part
i have nothing at this point but have
something and that so again Sigma Y is
decomposed into Sigma X and Sigma Z so I
have to write down this representing
this point and this coordinate is
translated to this monomial and I again
placed a plus placeholder
so let's do this exercise for the Torah
code model I have to define in my unit
cell because square that is with at with
a cubits on energy is equivalent to
having a pure of conventional square
lattice with two cubits per site for the
unit cell is also sitting like this then
I have a four by two matrix where each
row describes labeling in inside the
unit cell and the whether it is extra at
that time so going around the one
particular operator I write down
accordingly monomials in place the plus
sign as a placeholder and since there is
no Sigma Z part I just write down to
zero and likewise for Sigma Z top layer
so this matrix captures all the
information from the from your
Hamiltonian cubic hell we could have
this representation or we could have
this diagram to to remember the
positions of Sigma star Z or
equivalently we could just write down
mode of polynomial there are all
equivalent equivalent locations but here
bar means that means that all monomials
are have opposite a minus exponent
so you see the Sigma X operator if it
has a almost inverse parity spatial
inversion so that's why the bar appears
so now I have a very compact description
of my Hamiltonian so I can do
calculations on top of it and you can
work out that any preferred operation
meaning that unitary that there's a poly
operator to another poly operator can be
written as a row operation on that
matrix so we just apply some row
operation on this matrix to to find the
equivalent representation in the pub and
the Hamiltonian and another interesting
operation that you should do is that you
should take a course translation group
originally we had a 1 1 unit of the
translation was encoded in this monomial
however because I'm doing because I'm
going to do the RG where the length
scale is double I have to reinterpret my
translation group to be a smaller one
and according to that here's a
prescription even any polynomial in an
entry you just replace X with this
matrix and Y with is diagonal one and Z
with that this corresponds to the taking
enlarging your unit cell that combines
one at the origin and one at the x
position
well this is just technical detail you
don't have to worry too much better not
yet well so the sequence of seen us
corresponds to some row operation but
right but in this in this description
you can only have a sequence of sinners
that who's whose periodicity is equal to
your original lattice periodicity but we
don't want that because we are going to
apply unitary on the super block which
breaks your original translation
structure while
this is coarse graining it is so all
right right well if you say if you had
to say if you had a iso model just
ferromagnetic paralyzed model then here
my translation is what this Hamiltonian
is translating verifying translating one
union lattice spacing however I could
take a unit cell to be two qubits in
that case I would have to write down the
two kinds of interaction terms
this is one international term that acts
on the fly inside my unit sale
well the circle one point is circle two
means that one particular qubit inside
your unit cell and there should be
another term
at couples think of nearby it sells so
you really need to increase your
description of mattress once you realize
that and the calculation should be done
you on your computer because I'm gonna
dealing with that pretty large matrix
it's almost like a 64 by 32 so I rather
met with a district straight where a
Hamiltonian is including the mat matrix
and my oh my the product of C gnosis is
written as a script and later on after a
lot of C nuts you discover that the
original model and something else input
taking the the new model has an input I
again do some C not as some basis change
and I finally discover that there are
exactly so two coffees
original
and that this is the way I could do the
proclamation of that hundred quota
starting otherwise I wouldn't be able to
okay so I have briefly review of some
properly accurate code and by
representing them into a contact or I
was able to calculate some unitary
transformation such that your ground
state becomes a tensor product of the
two one image is similar to the original
and the other is not and for the other
one there's another anima circuit that
is nintendos into two copies of yourself
and this directly leads you through so
called branch America scription for your
own crafting so my interpretation of
this phenomena is as follows isn't
another very strong statement in the
fabrication is because qubits in the
block that you have Groot are so
entangled with the outside so that you
cannot choose a single representative
from that block in order to represent
properly your intended structure and
interestingly that happens at all scales
it doesn't converge to an our
conventional nature
and it suggests that the notion of art a
fixed point at least in the scheme of
containment RG is quite a subtle matter
they don't come something that really
scary times
oh so your question is can I multiply
them all slightly so that this happens
there 7500 that part I believe that's
pretty important question is this only
addresses a single say six points and
because it addresses how
because of the jealousy from this object
yes well you give me the extra
ingredients I mean each point here was
Tina listen degenerate but if that is
given you think if we know that these
points aren't degenerate
van Eyck answer them so you should it
should the most places that the
transition multiply as you go down the
level you have to multiply all together
okay but gives exactly the situational -
yes it's to do that was one who has like
a unique chance anyone before
right before something said yeah that
part is tricky because he care system
size is another power of truth that how
would you group them into two it's not a
bipartite
this requires it to consider only the
system sizes that it's part you know
regression that well the company do you
think very much individual but to the
visual limit well in that case you
exactly observe this red circle
phenomena I mean if you start with the
two-dimensional fixed point Manali
functions used to step it then obviously
if you if you're blocking includes at
least two copies of it then you should
have some friendship so french micelle
doesn't tell you much
however in this blue diagram this
function and that motion are different
that wouldn't happen in the stacks
if your computer problem can interpret
and I imagine it's no longer constant
like gas extraction a baby your ass on
camera for these year term basically
again
well chopstick if a ton of you basis
stacking you know look like that your
sugar has any dependence on the size or
shape but whether these cubic hold on
some signal everything well there is a
very crude not an argument the crude
calculation along that you can think of
a tough loss maintain the manager of B
with respect to the partition of solvent
horse but the contribution I mean sub
leading term next to the surface and at
the boundary term depends on the
orientation of that
and so little I'm okay soy tourists all
these moment yes so that says it's
pretty similar to the stack of Torah
codes however the job of stacking
doesn't really match with the lattice
Thresh's but that the fire of the
erection falls back in action there's a
certain orientation where we can see the
public not to the scale you need the
erection without yeah that I think that
is possible
well there are such a particular
direction I think so
that's kind of commercial ring with like
it's all sometimes a nitrate direction
well I did a Christian identically pour
too much because the notion of
entanglement entropy in higher
dimensions it's not really well to fire
questions thank you again